something that you'll find only on cbs
mornings oprah is in winfrey announcing
her latest pick for her book club and
this is a hint it's a new memoir from a
woman who stole our hearts on tv on the
big screen and on the stage
oprah joins us joined us recently along
with the author remotely from oprah's
porch in hawaii
oprah start us off with this because you
really don't pick many memoirs for your
book club but this one you made an
exception why why did you choose this
particular memoir well it wasn't even an
exception gail i have to tell you that i
read the first sentence and then the
first paragraph and i knew that this was
going to be a book club and let me tell
you what it is and the reason why it's
called
finding
me
by viola david look at the cover just
let us sit at that look at that cover
for just a second it's so striking
what's striking is this biola that we
know and let me tell you
anybody who's loved viola davis you were
a big fan of how to get away with murder
you've watched over the years let me you
do not know viola davis
you don't know viola davis until you
until you meet this girl gail have you
seen this no i haven't seen any of this
davis there ladies and gentlemen let me
introduce viola davis
bravo
bravo viola davis
viola davis congratulations
what did you think when you found out
that you were an oprah book club pick
i'm curious
i flipped out you did i am not going to
lie the fact that she received it yes
the fact that she got it you know a lot
of times you don't think people are
going to get your story especially when
when you've had it bound up inside you
for so long and there's so much shame
attached to it oprah what stood out to
you about this book
well what spoke to me is that you know i
i also grew up poor but i say i bow to
your poorness because yes
i don't know anybody with a story as poe
is this
who managed to not just poor but
colorism racism sexism violence sexual
abuse everything
and to find a way
to literally fight your way out to have
that thing inside you that says
uh i've been denied but i will not live
the rest of my life being denied i mean
i think that there there's so much hope
and so much power in her story that you
know she has done exactly what uh
writing a great memoir does you you let
your words uh embolden other people
viola you start the book by saying i was
a spunky sassy mess i love that you were
all so competitive you were also shy
prime picking for bullies but let's talk
about your bullies for just a second
because these people were just they
weren't just i'm going to beat you up
i'm going to kick you but they were
cruel what did they do
well well they would chase me every
single day after school every day
with every single day and i was a really
fast runner and
with the potty mouth yeah i say yes yes
but um
but the eight or nine boys they would
pick up anything they could find on the
side of the road but here's the thing
with them they're just an extension of
what central falls was at the time
um but more importantly what america was
at the time
we were the only black family in first
black family in central falls and a
couple of other cape verdeans moved in
or whatever
i think it was their response to my
blackness yeah
it's them spitting out the very thing
about america that america even hated at
the time
what that does to a little girl
to be told that you are nothing you are
worthless and you are ugly and that's
what that's what hurt me so much biola
and it's what hurt me too yeah
because i believe them you believe them
and you know as you know they tell you
to fight my mom told me to fight bala
don't come home yes until you beat their
butt yes you don't come home and so i
fought and i fought them and i made them
stop
but i didn't know
how to fight that feeling inside that
i'm not what you say that i am you know
you also write something that most
people don't talk about colorism well
there's been something really deeply
interjected in our
uh in our culture
about beauty
and classic beauty and womanhood
and that paper bag test
did a number on us
and we created that
and the darker you are from the paper
bag the more
less intelligent you are
the ugly less attractive you are yes
and here's the thing
the most important thing this is the
biggest issue i have the less valuable
you are
beauty is attached to a value
and if you don't have it you have
nothing
once i got older into my 40s
i started asking a really really
important question which is
why
who said yes i'm not beautiful
and then
something
happened within all of that this little
flicker this little voice that said
i have the power to reject that
that is an opinion
that is not the truth
oprah what did you think about viola's
comments about colorism well i thought
what what i thought was so liberating
was how she was able to express in
finding me
how
how to get away with murder yeah really
changed her life yes being able to bring
beauty
sexuality a sense of value
importance and power to that character
and to be able to express that to the
world through annelise yeah and and
speaking of playing a role i i like
viola how you said you looked at cicely
tyson and you thought oh
i want to do that
and the way you looked up to cicely
tyson is the way so many people now look
up to you
they're looking up to you saying i want
to be like viola davis i want to do that
what does that mean to you
it means everything to me
you know i'll tell you when i looked
into the eyes of so many young
especially dark-skinned young girls
which that's a whole other narrative
right there yeah yeah
and they feel like i've given them
permission to see themselves
as a thing of beauty as a thing of
possibilities
absolutely it gives me a different kind
of joy than i get from even my oscar my
emmy and all of those other
awards and accomplishments i'll wrap it
up with you said you lived with the
shame for so long but now you don't live
with the shame you see this as warrior
fuel i love that because it is so raw
and so personal are you apprehensive
about it coming out
oh yes absolutely are you
i'm apprehensive i'm apprehensive of the
criticism i'm apprehensive about how
it's gonna affect my family i'm
apprehensive but here's my thing
i
don't think that there's living without
risks
i don't
i think if you risk not you live not
how powerful all right viola davis i i
think we should point out guys that
viola is official spokeswoman for
l'oreal paris that's a big deal because
she said growing up she never thought
that she would have a beauty contract of
any time of any kind but we see
differently of course especially when
you look at the cover but jamie you'll
in particular get a kick out of this
tony you're excused because you have
love in your life and you're married
when oprah read the book she called me
right away and she said first you need
to get the book and get on your knees
because viola davis is a big manifesto
and so she said a friend told her get on
her knees and pray out loud for a man
that she wants jamie and i've had men
conversations many times that's why i
can have this conversation with jamie
she said at first jamie she was hesitant
because she didn't normally pray but she
asked for this a big black man who was
an ex-football player from the south
because she thought they were cute okay
who's been married before and had kids
so she wouldn't be pressured for kids
okay but an artistic artistic mindset
who loved god and three and a half weeks
later she met her husband julius tennant
wow
isn't that a good story you know
she's moving in with her boyfriend she's
doing well
boy
my stuff comes out doesn't it oh you
have a boyfriend now
we got to catch up we did a full team
okay jamie lucas
i guess it's just me on my knees over
his interview with viola davis oprah
viola netflix special event
i'm so glad
and on oprah daily you can get a
conversation with oprah insiders and
viola and oprah talking about the book
her memoir finding me will be available
on tuesday